Big-ears means simply taking even more surface area in — folding it in. Very, very high sink rates, really very high sink values, already in straight flight, and with a little bit of roll and weight shift we can reach values in the double-digit range, so very easily and without much physical strain.
But it's more of an advanced technique, so we only do it at the end of training.
Still, I want to give you this one too, because it's another option and really useful for losing altitude when you absolutely have to.
The technique is practically identical to little-ears, except that we now take two A-lines on the right and two on the left.
Again, the brake stays at the loop in the hand. Why? That's of course for re-inflating — we always have to be a bit ready for that.
That's why we keep the brakes in our hands, then take the accelerator, again gently push the bar, symmetrically. And now the important part: we have to try to grab the outermost A-line on the right plus the A-line next to it.
And we now must not pull too low down — that is, not too close to the line-lock — because otherwise we'd pull the innermost A-line along with it and end up with a full collapse, a frontal.
And that's why we have to try to grip as high as possible, high above the line-lock; then we can kink them first and then pull down, and then we push the bar.
If the ears end up folded in firmly, we can let our hands come up a little, fold in slightly less ear, and so we can even fine-tune the size of the ears a bit.
Then perhaps fix them at the position you have, or you can keep them like that — whatever suits.
Simply fix them to the main riser as close as possible, then with weight shift either increase the sink rate or not, just keep the wing straight — whichever you want.
And for the exit it's now important: we stay fully in the accelerator, release the A-lines symmetrically up, and if the ears stay in, pump them — but with full bar.
And only once the ears are out do we come fully off the bar again.
Easy — you just have to do it a few times.
Don't be alarmed: at the start a lot of surface area gets folded in, and that can leave you a bit shocked at first, but we'll train the whole thing a few times.
And the key point is that you also try to look up and see how much have I actually folded in.
If it's too much and the wing isn't really properly open in the middle, we let the A-lines up a bit and naturally end up with a little...
...more room to actually steer the wing and stay on heading and course.